It's the fall of 1918. The Great War is raging. More than a million American men have found themselves in the Muzargon offensive on the Western Front. It remains, to this day, the deadliest campaign in our military's history, and the conditions were horrendous. So it's rainy, it's muddy, it's freezing, and this is the beginning of trench warfare. These soldiers are hanging out in ditches in the mud. people are dying everywhere. It's miserable.
那是1918年的秋天。第一次世界大战正打得如火如荼。超过一百万的美国士兵发现自己身处西线的默兹-阿尔贡攻势之中。直到今天，这仍然是我们军事史上最惨烈的战役，而且当时的条件极其恶劣。到处是雨水、泥泞和严寒，这就是堑壕战的开端。士兵们蜷缩在泥泞的沟渠里。到处都有人死去。那真是太悲惨了。
Avery Truffleman is the host of Articles of Interest, a show about fashion and design. So when she thinks about this miserable, awful war, she thinks about what the soldiers are wearing. They are in wool overcoats, which, you know, if you're going on a walk and it's cold outside, wool can be a really great fabric. If you're a soldier fighting and running for your life,
艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）是《感兴趣的物品》（Articles of Interest）节目的主持人，这是一档关于时尚与设计的节目。所以，当她想到这场悲惨、可怕的战争时，她会想到士兵们穿的是什么。他们穿着羊毛大衣，你知道的，如果你是在外面散步，天气又冷，羊毛确实是一种非常棒的面料。但如果你是一名正在战斗、为了活命而奔跑的士兵，
a giant wool overcoat is horrible because it gets really wet and it gets really heavy and then you want to take it off and then suddenly you're freezing. You just have one wool blanket that is usually wet and dirty and then they were trapped in these awful things. The very thing that was supposed to keep these soldiers safe and warm instead caused a lot of harm. Because back then, the military didn't consider fashion a technology. They were focused on weapons, artillery, supply lines, communication. They didn't think of clothing as something to help or hurt the war effort.
一件巨大的羊毛大衣简直是灾难，因为它会变得非常湿重，然后你想把它脱掉，可脱掉后你又会立刻冻僵。他们通常只有一条又湿又脏的羊毛毯子，然后就被困在这些糟糕的东西里。原本应该保护这些士兵、让他们保持温暖的东西，反而造成了巨大的伤害。因为在当时，军方并不认为时尚是一种技术。他们专注于武器、火炮、补给线和通讯。他们没想过服装是能够帮助或损害战争进程的东西。
It was just what soldiers wore. And beyond that, the American military went into World War I totally unprepared for the climate. We had fought a war abroad before the Spanish-American War, which was like a warm weather war. And that's when we started wearing khaki. But we had never fought in like the wilds of northern Europe before. This is like extremely cold, exotic climate for the United States. And we didn't really know what we were doing yet on a large scale. So a lot of soldiers suffered.
那只是士兵穿的衣服而已。不仅如此，美国军队在参加第一次世界大战时，对气候完全没有准备。我们在美西战争之前曾在海外打过仗，那是一场温暖气候下的战争。也就是从那时起，我们开始穿卡其布服装。但我们以前从未在北欧那种荒野中作战过。这对美国来说是一种极度寒冷、陌生的气候。而且在大规模作战方面，我们当时还真的不知道自己在做什么。所以很多士兵受了苦。
Did the military realize they had made a mistake issuing these coats to soldiers? Absolutely. Once the war ended, they were like, we've got to find a better jacket. But after the Great War, they were like, let's not focus on war right now. We're never going to have a big war ever again. And that was really bad. Yeah, it was the war to end all wars. The war to end all wars.
军方是否意识到给士兵发放这些大衣是个错误？绝对意识到了。战争一结束，他们就想，我们得找一件更好的夹克。但在“大战”之后，他们觉得，我们现在别关注战争了。我们再也不会打大仗了。这真的很糟糕。是的，那是结束所有战争的战争。结束所有战争的战争。
Yeah. So, like, that was a weird experiment. They didn't think that they needed to revisit or redesign such a jacket for such an expansive war in Europe. But when it proved true that we did end up fighting another giant war in Europe, it was time to revisit this jacket problem. The jacket problem. How should the American military outfit its soldiers? to make them as safe and effective as possible. And how should such a jacket be developed?
是的。所以，那是一次奇怪的实验。他们认为不需要为欧洲这样一场大规模的战争去重新审视或设计这样一件夹克。但当事实证明我们最终确实在欧洲又打了一场巨大的战争时，是时候重新审视这个夹克问题了。夹克问题。美国军队应该如何装备士兵？才能让他们尽可能安全且高效。而且这样一件夹克应该如何开发？
And underneath that, what happens when a symbol of military might gets stripped of its connection to the military and hits the streets? From 99% Invisible in BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States in 100 objects. I'm Roman Mars. Today, the incredible origin and evolution
在此之下，当一个军事力量的象征被剥离了与军队的联系并流向街头时，会发生什么？来自BBC工作室的《99%隐形》（99% Invisible），这是《100件物品中的美国史》。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。今天，是M-43陆军野战夹克令人难以置信的起源和演变。
of the M-43 Army Field Jacket. The field jacket changed what it meant to be a soldier and to look like a soldier. And it changed what we all wear every day, not only Americans, but all around the world. The United States military did not put their soldiers in wool overcoats because they thought it was the best technology. They did it because other countries put their soldiers in wool overcoats.
野战夹克改变了作为一名士兵的意义，也改变了士兵的外观。它改变了我们每个人每天穿的东西，不仅是美国人，而是全世界的人。美国军方让士兵穿上羊毛大衣，并不是因为他们认为这是最好的技术。他们这样做是因为其他国家让他们的士兵穿羊毛大衣。
For more than a century, they had just copied the current military superpower of the moment. You can see this very clearly in the Revolutionary War. we're basically dressing exactly like the British. It's just like they're wearing red and we're not. Then you see this in the Civil War where we're actually dressing French. Like that was the superpower at the time. And it's funny because when you look at it,
一个多世纪以来，他们只是在模仿当时的世界军事超级大国。这一点在独立战争中表现得非常明显。我们基本上穿得和英国人一模一样。就像他们穿红色，而我们不穿。然后你在内战中也能看到这一点，我们实际上穿的是法式服装。因为那是当时的超级大国。有趣的是，当你观察它时，
we do kind of look like the soldiers from the Nutcracker. It's very like jaunty little tin soldiers. But that's what we're imitating. We're imitating the French. And then we had this really weird period, which is my favorite in military history, where we were imitating the Prussians and we wore like plumed hats
我们看起来确实有点像《胡桃夹子》里的士兵。非常像那种轻快的小锡兵。但这就是我们在模仿的东西。我们在模仿法国人。然后我们经历了一个非常奇怪的时期，这是我在军事史上最喜欢的时期，当时我们在模仿普鲁士人，我们戴着插羽毛的帽子，
and the helmets with the little spike on top. Like, we wore those. We just copied whoever was the global superpower at the time. And that was the way military fashion worked. It was like, we want to look like the powerful ones. And that decision was sort of made top down. So by 1941, it's clear that the U.S. is going to join World War II. And the military knows it needs a better jacket.
还有头顶带尖刺的头盔。没错，我们戴过那些。我们只是复制了当时谁是全球超级大国。这就是军事时尚的运作方式。就像是，我们想看起来像那些强大的国家。而那个决定在某种程度上是自上而下做出的。所以到了1941年，很明显美国要加入第二次世界大战了。军方知道它需要一件更好的夹克。
So how does it approach this problem? So there were a few kind of improvised solutions that were made. This one general, General Parsons, was like, my boys need something a little lighter just to wear when they're going out. When it's just a little windy and they don't want a full wool coat. And so what he did was he ordered like 300 golf jackets, like members-only jackets. And he picked the parts he liked and he was like, sew these all together.
那么它是如何解决这个问题的呢？当时有一些即兴的解决方案。有一位将军，帕森斯将军（General Parsons），他说，我的小伙子们需要一些更轻便的东西，只是在他们外出时穿。当风有点大，他们又不想穿厚重的羊毛大衣时。于是他订购了大约300件高尔夫夹克，就像那种会员专属夹克。他挑选了自己喜欢的部件，然后说，把这些缝在一起。
And then they made this golf jacket, which was like so cool. So it's like a zip-up jacket, basically. It's like a windbreaker. comes in like a khaki-ish color. Little slip pockets on the side. It looks very modern. And this cool windbreaker became known colloquially as the Parsons jacket
然后他们就做出了这件高尔夫夹克，看起来非常酷。它基本上是一件拉链夹克。就像一件防风衣。颜色是卡其色的。侧面有小插袋。看起来非常现代。而这件酷酷的防风衣被通俗地称为“帕森斯夹克”，
after General Parsons. All the soldiers wanted one, although they were terrible for soldiers. If you raised your arm, your belly would get exposed. It really didn't work if it was a little cold outside. It was not a very pragmatic, practical, like soldier looking jacket.
以帕森斯将军的名字命名。所有的士兵都想要一件，尽管它们对士兵来说很糟糕。如果你抬起手臂，你的肚子就会露出来。如果外面有点冷，它真的没用。它不是一件非常务实、实用、看起来像士兵穿的夹克。
And so eventually all these battalions one by one, we're like, well, we want our version of the Parsons jacket. Like, can we make one for parachuting? Can we make one for tankers? Can we make one that's lined for cold environments? And then the government is like issuing all these limited edition drops of this jacket for all these different battalions. And it is so impractical.
于是最终，所有的营队一个接一个地表示，好吧，我们想要我们自己版本的帕森斯夹克。比如，我们能为伞兵做一件吗？我们能为坦克兵做一件吗？我们能做一件有内衬的来适应寒冷环境吗？然后政府就开始为所有这些不同的营队发放这些限量版的夹克。这太不切实际了。
It's like jacket chaos. Yeah. So there's an effort to streamline this to make the one perfect jacket. So talk to me about how you take on that monumental task. This grand task was taken on by a professor named George Dorio. He was a business professor at Harvard. He was an immigrant.
简直是“夹克混乱”。是的。所以有人努力去精简它，制造出一件完美的夹克。那么，跟我说说你是如何承担这项艰巨任务的吧。这项宏大的任务是由一位名叫乔治·多里奥（George Doriot）的教授承担的。他是哈佛大学的一名商业教授。他是一位移民。
He was French, and he was a high-ranking official in the French military. And he was like, I can feel this war coming. I'm probably going to be put in charge of some big thing because I'm a business professor and a veteran. And so he kind of decided to work. in the logistics arm. He was like, I'll do this. He sort of volunteered himself. He was like, they need someone who knows how to organize things. The funny thing is George Adoria is not famous for his work in jacket organizing. He is famous for being the inventor of venture capital.
他是法国人，曾是法国军队的一名高级军官。他当时想，我能感觉到战争即将来临。我可能会被委以重任，因为我既是商业教授又是退伍军人。于是他决定在后勤部门工作。他说，我来做这个。他算是自告奋勇。他说，他们需要一个懂得如何组织事物的人。有趣的是，乔治·多里奥并不是因为他在夹克组织方面的工作而闻名。他因发明了风险投资而闻名。
This whole thing is a giant footnote in his life, which is, I mean, it's very funny that this whole story is just like a fun fact about this guy. Anyway, so he takes on whatever project the military needs help doing. And this big project that they present to him is like, okay, we need a jacket. We need one superior jacket that will look great, work in every environment for every job that a soldier has to do. Huge task.
整件事在他的人生中只是一个巨大的脚注，我的意思是，这个故事竟然只是关于这个家伙的一个趣闻，这非常有趣。总之，他接手了军方需要帮助的任何项目。他们交给他的这个大项目是，好吧，我们需要一件夹克。我们需要一件卓越的夹克，它看起来很棒，在每种环境下都能为士兵必须做的每项工作发挥作用。艰巨的任务。
And Dori does this amazing thing. He starts working from first principles. Again, this sounds so obvious now. But before this, the military was just being like, who's the most powerful military or what does some general want? This guy is like, well, what does keep people warm? You know, like, what does repel the rain? And even though the field of physiology was budding,
多里奥做了一件了不起的事情。他开始从第一性原理出发。再说一次，这听起来现在太显而易见了。但在那之前，军方只是在想，谁是最强大的军队，或者某个将军想要什么？而这个家伙却在想，什么能让人保暖？你知道，什么能防雨？尽管生理学领域当时才刚刚起步，
and yeah, there were all these labs at Harvard that were putting students on treadmills and testing how much they could sweat and body heat retention, no one had done this to clothing yet. He was like, well, let's spray water at this jacket. You know, let's blow wind at this jacket. Let's use laboratories. Let's really figure out objectively what the best jacket is.
是的，哈佛大学的所有实验室都在让学生在跑步机上测试他们能出多少汗以及身体热量保持情况，但还没有人把这些应用到服装上。他说，好吧，让我们向这件夹克喷水。你知道，让我们向这件夹克吹风。让我们利用实验室。让我们真正客观地找出最好的夹克是什么。
And George Doria was so invested in finding the objectively greatest jacket that he was like human test subjects aren't even enough anymore because what's cold to you? What's warm to you? So he ordered a copper dummy that was fitted out with sensors and then they put the dummy in the cold and in the heat and overnight and put different jackets on the dummy and tested, okay, which jacket keeps the dummy the warmest?
乔治·多里奥对寻找客观上最棒的夹克投入了极大的热情，以至于他说人类测试对象已经不够用了，因为对你来说什么是冷？对你来说什么是暖？所以他订购了一个装有传感器的铜制假人，然后他们把假人放在寒冷和炎热的环境中，过夜，给假人穿上不同的夹克，测试哪件夹克能让假人保持最温暖。
I mean, rigorous, rigorous, repeated tests. Yeah. And the copper mannequin had the name. Yes. The mannequin's name was Chauncey. Very important point. And this is what makes me live out. You know, he was like, what will make the boys the most comfortable?
我的意思是，严谨、严谨、反复的测试。是的。而且那个铜制人体模型还有名字。是的。那个模型叫昌西（Chauncey）。非常重要的一点。这就是让我感动的地方。你知道，他当时想，什么能让小伙子们最舒服？
Like, how beautiful is that? It wasn't about emulating some other army. It wasn't about what some high-ranking general wanted. It was about the people, the army of the people. and making sure they were comfortable and they were safe and they were protected. And it just makes me want to tear up a little. I'm like, this is what we were supposed to be doing the whole time. It's so cool.
这多美好啊？这不是为了模仿其他军队。这不是为了满足某个高级将军的愿望。这是为了人民，为了人民的军队。确保他们舒适、安全、受到保护。这让我有点想流泪。我想，这才是我们一直应该做的事情。这太酷了。
And this was wild at the time to be like, we're going to treat clothes like a technology. This is as important as developing a tank or a bomb or anything else. This is military technology. Okay, so after putting Chauncey through rigorous testing, what did they find? They found that there is no one perfect jacket. They found that the best way to get different temperatures for different environments is to use a radical new concept called layering, which is like, wom, wom, I could have told you that.
在当时，把衣服当作一种技术来对待是非常疯狂的。这和开发坦克、炸弹或其他任何东西一样重要。这是军事技术。好吧，那么在让昌西经过严苛的测试后，他们发现了什么？他们发现没有一件完美的夹克。他们发现，在不同环境下获得不同温度的最佳方法是使用一种激进的新概念，叫做“分层穿衣法”，这就像是，哎呀，我早就能告诉你了。
But they discovered that. That's what they discovered. But you couldn't have told us that in 1941. I definitely could not have told you that because they were like, oh, we just have this one wool jacket and this one lighter jacket. No, this was so revolutionary, this idea of layering. The layers that George Dorio's team came up with included a liner for warmth, a parka for the cold, and a waterproof shell for rain. It was all part of a system, and at the heart of this system was a jacket.
但他们发现了这一点。这就是他们的发现。但在1941年你可没法告诉我们。我绝对没法告诉你，因为他们当时想，哦，我们只有这一件羊毛夹克和这一件轻便夹克。不，这种分层穿衣的想法太具有革命性了。乔治·多里奥团队提出的分层包括用于保暖的内衬、用于防寒的派克大衣，以及用于防雨的防水外壳。这一切都是系统的一部分，而这个系统的核心就是一件夹克。
It is a cotton, sateen, olive drab, floppy field jacket. four large cargo pockets, two at the hip, two at the breast. It's got adjustable cuffs. It's about hip length, draw strings around the waist so that you could tighten all the layers around yourself. It had this collar that you could turn up against the wind. It had all these features. But it wasn't about the jacket.
那是一件棉质、缎纹、橄榄褐色的宽松野战夹克。有四个大货运口袋，两个在臀部，两个在胸前。它有可调节的袖口。长度大约到臀部，腰部有抽绳，这样你就可以把所有的层紧紧地系在身上。它有一个可以翻起来抵御风的领子。它有所有这些功能。但重点不在于夹克本身。
It was about like the layers of the jacket and the system of the jacket. And this scientific system of a jacket was called the M-43. And the M stands for model, 1943, year it was made. M43 jacket, which is a, you know, scientific name for this, like, piece of science.
重点在于夹克的层次和夹克的系统。而这种科学的夹克系统被称为M-43。M代表型号（Model），1943是它制造的年份。M43夹克，这是一个科学名称，代表了这件科学产物。
Mm-hmm. It was so radical-looking. I mean, now it doesn't look so weird because all modern outdoor clothes look like this. They're all modular. They're all a little baggy. They all have these different layers and hoods and elements and draw strings and stuff like that.
嗯。它看起来太激进了。我的意思是，现在看起来没那么奇怪了，因为所有现代户外服装看起来都像这样。它们都是模块化的。它们都有点宽松。它们都有这些不同的层次、兜帽、元素和抽绳之类的东西。
This was so completely, I mean, this was alien. Early jackets came with instructions printed on the inside of like, when it's raining, put on your hood and, you know, tighten it with the drawstrings. Yeah. It is kind of frumpy. Like it's sort of like it's sort of born with wrinkles and the wrinkles now come back. And it's not the tight soldierly, you know, look. And you were supposed to live in this thing.
这在当时完全是，我的意思是，这简直是外星产物。早期的夹克内侧印有说明，比如，下雨时，戴上兜帽，你知道，用抽绳系紧。是的。它有点邋遢。就像它天生就带着褶皱，而这些褶皱现在又回来了。它不是那种紧身的军人形象。而且你必须穿着这件东西生活。
And it had been tested not only in the laboratory, but they also took. later prototypes of it out into the field, into a battle in Italy. They sent it to a thousand troops and got their feedback. And, you know, the pockets were specifically designed to fit a ration pack. You know, you could really live out of these things. They were sort of perfectly designed for the life of the average foot soldier. Yeah, yeah. I mean, the product testing with actual soldiers in the field and also the focus on function and comfort seems completely new. Super new. Super duper new. It was not about looks. It was not a costume. It was scientific, democratic, and it treated this soldier as kind of this new job in this new kind of war.
它不仅在实验室里经过了测试，他们还把后期的原型带到了实地，带到了意大利的战场上。他们把它发给了一千名士兵并获得了他们的反馈。而且，你知道，口袋是专门设计用来装口粮包的。你知道，你真的可以靠这些东西生活。它们在某种程度上是为普通步兵的生活而完美设计的。是的，是的。我的意思是，在实地对真实士兵进行产品测试，以及对功能和舒适度的关注，看起来完全是全新的。超级新。超级超级新。它不是为了外观。它不是戏服。它是科学的、民主的，它把士兵视为这种新型战争中的一种新职业。
So it's called M43, which means it was developed in 1943. Was this this Eureka moment? They found the jacket, therefore it was outfitted with everyone and therefore we won the war, hooray? You'd think, you'd think. You'd be like, yay, you did it. George Dorio, you found the perfect jacket. Nope, nope, nope. Because this is the part where we encounter the villain of our story. And his name was General Robert McGowan Little John.
所以它叫M43，意味着它是1943年开发的。这是一个“尤里卡”时刻吗？他们找到了这件夹克，因此每个人都装备上了，所以我们赢得了战争，万岁？你会这么想，你会这么想。你会觉得，耶，你们做到了。乔治·多里奥，你找到了完美的夹克。不，不，不。因为这就是我们遇到故事反派的部分。他的名字叫罗伯特·麦高恩·利特尔约翰将军（General Robert McGowan Little John）。
General Little John. And General Little John is a career soldier. He went to West Point. You know, he played it all completely by the book. He rose up the ranks. And he ended up as the quartermaster for the European Theater of Operations. And the quartermaster is basically the one in charge of logistics. They're in charge of boots, beans, and bullets, getting supplies to the boys in Europe.
利特尔约翰将军。利特尔约翰将军是一名职业军人。他毕业于西点军校。你知道，他完全按部就班。他一路晋升。最终成为了欧洲战区（ETO）的军需官。军需官基本上就是负责后勤的人。他们负责靴子、豆子和子弹，负责把补给运送到欧洲的小伙子们手中。
And in 1943, this meant England and Italy. And, like, pretend we haven't talked about the M-43, right? Okay, yeah. So in 1941 and 42, the military has the Parsons jacket, which is very cool-looking. but not practical, and different divisions want their own versions. Okay, so we're back in jacket chaos early on. Little John is over in Europe, and he sees all this jacket chaos, and he's like, I'm going to fix it.
而在1943年，这意味着英国和意大利。而且，假装我们还没谈过M-43，好吗？好的。所以在1941年和42年，军方有帕森斯夹克，看起来很酷，但不实用，不同的师想要他们自己的版本。好吧，所以我们回到了早期的“夹克混乱”。利特尔约翰在欧洲，他看到了所有的夹克混乱，他说，我要解决它。
He doesn't really know that the government is planning this giant. It's like Manhattan Project of Jackets is happening, yeah. He doesn't know. He doesn't realize that. And he's doing it the old school way where it's like, I'm a high-ranking general. I'm going to take matters into my own hands. I'm going to make a jacket,
他并不知道政府正在计划这个巨大的项目。这就像是夹克界的“曼哈顿计划”正在进行，是的。他不知道。他没意识到这一点。他正用老派的方式做事，就像是，我是一名高级将军。我要亲自处理这件事。我要做一件夹克，
and I'm going to make the one jacket that every soldier will need. So he functionally likes the look of the British battle dress jacket. And based on that, he goes to a factory in England and he's like, make me one of those with a few little tweaks. And he makes admittedly a very sharp looking jacket. I love it. It's like a wool jacket, but it's short-waisted. It's very tight. It's very dignified.
我要做一件每个士兵都需要的一件夹克。所以他在功能上喜欢英国战斗服夹克的外观。基于此，他去了英国的一家工厂，说，给我做一件那样的，稍微改动一下。他确实做了一件看起来非常干练的夹克。我喜欢它。它就像一件羊毛夹克，但腰部很短。它非常紧身。非常庄重。
It's very general Eisenhower. You got to be shaped like a Dorito chip to pull this off. It's like a very tight-fitting, elegant jacket. Yeah, yeah. And for him, he's like, oh, great, now this is like a more practical version of the wool jacket. Soldiers don't have to change back and forth between their fancy dress and their battle dress. This will be the one jacket to rule them all. He calls it the ETO jacket, ETO standing for European Theater of Operations.
非常像艾森豪威尔将军。你得长得像多力多滋薯片那样才能穿出效果。它是一件非常紧身、优雅的夹克。是的，是的。对他来说，他想，哦，太好了，现在这是一件比羊毛大衣更实用的版本。士兵们不必在他们的礼服和战斗服之间换来换去。这将是统治一切的一件夹克。他称之为ETO夹克，ETO代表欧洲战区。
And it has, like, a tie. It's not compared to what was happening with all the jacket chaos, it is more practical. But when you know that the M-43 jacket is like secretly being developed in a laboratory, the ETO jacket kind of looks like a joke. Yeah. You know? Because, you know, he's a general.
它有领带。与当时发生的夹克混乱相比，它确实更实用。但当你得知M-43夹克正秘密在实验室开发时，ETO夹克看起来就像个笑话。是的。你知道吗？因为，你知道，他是个将军。
So, like, his version of a versatile jacket is you stand out on a battlefield occasionally and then you go to a dinner occasionally or something like that. You know what I mean? Like those are his versions. It's not like a trench or, you know, jumping out of a plane or... Yeah, I think it'd been a while since he's been, like, boots on the ground. You didn't really know. what had been
所以，他心目中的多功能夹克就是你偶尔站在战场上，然后偶尔去吃个晚餐之类的。你知道我的意思吗？就像那些是他的版本。它不像战壕大衣，或者从飞机上跳下来……是的，我想他已经很久没有亲临前线了。他真的不知道，
a lot of changed in his time. But what is his thinking? Like, he must have some recognition that this is not the most practical jacket in the world. So what does Little John like about this? Yeah, so a big part of his logic, which I am sympathetic to, this is a time
在他那个时代已经发生了多少变化。但他的想法是什么？他一定意识到这不是世界上最实用的夹克。那么利特尔约翰喜欢它什么呢？是的，所以他的逻辑很大一部分，我是同情的，这是一个时代，
World War II, it's a huge draft. There are men pouring into the European theater who have never fought before. They've never known this kind of discipline. And to Little John, he sees the jacket as this soldier-making tool. Like, you want to be a soldier?
第二次世界大战，这是一场大规模的征兵。大批从未打过仗的男人涌入欧洲战区。他们从未经历过这种纪律。对利特尔约翰来说，他把夹克视为一种“士兵制造工具”。就像，你想成为一名士兵吗？
You got to dress like a soldier. In the same way, that's like you got to make your bed. You got to stand up straight. You got to wear this nice jacket. You got to come correct. You got to look good. You know, this is not about being comfortable. We're at war.
你得穿得像个士兵。同样地，就像你得整理床铺。你得站直。你得穿上这件漂亮的夹克。你得表现得体。你得看起来不错。你知道，这不是为了舒服。我们在打仗。
And also, I think a lot of it was presenting the American military to a European audience. Like, looking good. Looking classy. So this ambition does not a villain make. No. What makes General Little John a villain? What makes a villain a villain is vindictiveness. And what's really fitting is I met this incredible military historian named Joshua Kerner.
而且，我认为很大一部分是为了向欧洲观众展示美国军队。看起来不错。看起来很有档次。所以这种野心并不能让他成为反派。不。什么让利特尔约翰将军成为反派？让反派成为反派的是报复心。非常贴切的是，我遇到了一位了不起的军事历史学家，名叫约书亚·克纳（Joshua Kerner）。
Kerner is really, really into archives and research almost obsessively. And he's uncovered a lot of this story of the field jacket that I'm about to tell you. But basically, Kerner was going through old documents. and realized General Little John did something really terrible. So what did General Little John do? Little John first catches wind of the M-43 jacket. He was like, these look sloppy. What is this?
克纳对档案和研究非常痴迷。他揭开了我即将讲述的关于野战夹克的很多故事。但基本上，克纳在翻阅旧文件时，意识到利特尔约翰将军做了一件非常糟糕的事情。那么利特尔约翰将军做了什么？利特尔约翰首先听说了M-43夹克。他说，这些看起来太邋遢了。这是什么？
What is this thing that the government back at home is making without consulting me? My jackets are so much better than this frumpy, ugly stuff. He, like, makes a vow then and there that he will stop the M-43 jacket from ever reaching the wider military. Wow. So how does he go about stopping this? He has a tremendous amount of power. You know, he's in charge of all the supplies going into the European theater.
国内政府在不咨询我的情况下制造的这个东西是什么？我的夹克比这些邋遢、丑陋的东西好多了。他当时就发誓，他要阻止M-43夹克进入更广泛的军队。哇。那么他打算如何阻止呢？他拥有巨大的权力。你知道，他负责运往欧洲战区的所有补给。
And as the M-43 jacket is slowly getting rolled out, and Dorios, like, here you go, here's this jacket that I lovingly made and it's perfect. Little John's like, no, get those away from me, over my dead body. never. Our man of science, Doriot, is begging Little John, like, please, please take these jackets, you know, like winter. Winter is coming and you have to order these in advance. And this is a serious winter. And he just refuses to order them. In fact, there reaches a point where M43 jackets are like, packed up, ready to go to Europe. And he was like, nope, we got it. I made a jacket. I'm fine. Like, we're just going to wear my jacket over here. We don't need that. And he's making excuses. He's dragging his feet. He's putting it off for so long.
随着M-43夹克慢慢推出，多里奥说，给你，这是我精心制作的夹克，它是完美的。利特尔约翰说，不，把那些从我面前拿走，除非我死了。绝不。我们的科学人多里奥在恳求利特尔约翰，求求你，求求你接受这些夹克，你知道，冬天。冬天就要来了，你必须提前订购这些。这是一个严酷的冬天。但他就是拒绝订购。事实上，甚至到了M43夹克已经打包好，准备运往欧洲的时候。他说，不，我们有这个。我做了一件夹克。我很好。我们就在这里穿我的夹克。我们不需要那个。他在找借口。他在拖延。他推迟了太久。
And he's not really being transparent about like, I hate these jackets. He's just like, no, no, no thanks. You know, we don't need these. So in the fall of 1944, it doesn't seem like the war slowing down anytime soon. It's expanding throughout Europe. And all the quartermasters throughout the European Theater of Operations under Little John are turning to Little John. And they're like, hey, we don't have those new jackets that we heard about. We're probably unprepared.
而且他并没有真正坦诚地说，我讨厌这些夹克。他只是说，不，不，不，谢谢。你知道，我们不需要这些。所以到了1944年秋天，战争看起来并没有很快放缓的迹象。它正在整个欧洲蔓延。欧洲战区所有在利特尔约翰手下的军需官都在向利特尔约翰求助。他们说，嘿，我们没有听说过的那种新夹克。我们可能准备不足。
You can actually, like, Kerner found this letter from someone to Little John, and you can see how they have to tiptoe around him. He's like, just maybe, possibly it will be colder than you think. I know that you think you don't need these jackets, but maybe you do. It's like, and he, you can tell what a tyrant he is. Like, no one feels comfortable being like, please order the jackets. Finally, in the fall of 1944, Little John gives end to the undeniable superiority of the M-433. Jacket. Yeah, little John acquiesces
你实际上可以，克纳找到了某人写给利特尔约翰的一封信，你可以看到他们必须如何在他面前小心翼翼。他说，也许，可能天气会比你想象的更冷。我知道你认为你不需要这些夹克，但也许你需要。就像是，你可以看出他是个多么暴君的人。没有人觉得可以舒服地说，请订购这些夹克。最终，在1944年秋天，利特尔约翰屈服于M-43夹克不可否认的优越性。是的，利特尔约翰默许了，
and it's like, okay, fine, fine, let the jackets in. I don't even care, whatever. But all that gear is waiting back in the United States, so it takes months to reach the troops in Europe. Most troops will not begin
他说，好吧，好吧，让夹克进来吧。我根本不在乎，随便吧。但所有的装备都在美国等着，所以要花几个月时间才能到达欧洲的部队手中。大多数部队直到1945年1月才开始
receiving M43 jackets and adequate sleeping bags and footwear and all the other stuff Doreo designed until January, 1945. They had to go through like, you know, September, October, November, December, freezing. So by the time winter,
收到M43夹克、足够的睡袋、鞋子以及多里奥设计的其他所有东西。他们不得不经历九月、十月、十一月、十二月，在严寒中度过。所以当冬天，
hits. They're in ETO jackets. They're in like dress jackets. And it's horrible. They were freezing. Many of them developed trench foot, which is
来临时。他们穿着ETO夹克。他们穿着礼服夹克。这太可怕了。他们冻僵了。他们中的许多人患上了战壕足，这
disgusting. I don't want to gross anybody out, but like your skin falls off. It's nasty. And this is World War II. Communication technology has gotten really good. People know. Americans are getting notes from their sons being like, mom, dad, I'm freezing out here. I'm given inadequate
很恶心。我不想让任何人感到恶心，但你的皮肤会脱落。这很糟糕。这是第二次世界大战。通讯技术已经变得非常好了。人们知道。美国人收到儿子的信，说，妈妈，爸爸，我在这里冻僵了。我得到的夹克不合格。
jackets. There's a sense of outrage that is building back at home of like, why aren't our boys being taken care of? They're going to freeze to death out here. They start complaining. They turn to the press. They turn to the New York Times on the Washington Post. And this becomes a massive scandal. It's called the Cold Weather Crisis. It's a huge deal. I, you know, Joshua Kerner brought me into the quartermaster archives and we're looking at old newspapers that were covering this. This was on like page four of the
国内有一种愤怒正在积聚，人们想，为什么我们的孩子没有得到照顾？他们会冻死在那里的。他们开始抱怨。他们转向媒体。他们转向《纽约时报》和《华盛顿邮报》。这变成了一场巨大的丑闻。它被称为“寒冷天气危机”。这是一件大事。我，你知道，约书亚·克纳带我去了军需官档案馆，我们正在查看报道此事的旧报纸。这在《华盛顿邮报》的第四版上。这可不是什么时尚版的内容。它只是无法被忽视。所以利特尔约翰有没有得到报应？比如他有没有因为这件事受到指责？没有。没有人把这件事归咎于利特尔约翰将军。他完全
Washington Post. This is not like style section stuff. It's just unignorable. So does Little John ever get his comeuppance? Like does he ever get blamed for this? No. No one pins this on General Little John at all. He completely
逃脱了惩罚。他是怎么做到的？因为和德怀特·D·艾森豪威尔（Dwight D. Eisenhower）做朋友太好了，艾森豪威尔基本上为他的西点军校好友进行了干预。而且艾森豪威尔也喜欢ETO夹克。他理解他朋友的处境。他发布了一项媒体禁令。你不能说ETO夹克的任何坏话。他说，这是为了士气。你知道，我们必须支持军队，我们不能联合起来反对领导层。但我们都知道原因。这是朋友间的裙带关系。
gets away with it. How does he manage that? Because it's great to be friends with Dwight D. Eisenhower, who essentially ran interference for his buddy from West Point. And Eisenhower also loved the ETO jacket. He understood where his friend was coming from. And he issues a press moratorium. You can't say anything bad about the ETO jackets. And he's like, this is for morale. You know, we have to support the troops and we can't gang up on leadership. But we all know why. It was friend nepotism.
这是朋友间的裙带关系，是的。所以M-43野战夹克最终在1945年到达了欧洲士兵手中。这可不是利特尔约翰的功劳。接下来发生了什么？每个人都穿着这些很棒的夹克，军方正在大量生产这些东西，特别是因为我们正处于第二次世界大战的深处，作为未来的人，你和我都知道会有原子弹，它会结束第二次世界大战。但没人知道真正的“曼哈顿计划”实际上正在进行。军方的大多数人并不知道这一点。人们普遍认为这场战争还要持续好几年。是的，即使在欧洲战区某种程度上获胜之后。是的。人们认为我们将入侵日本。
There's a friend nepotism, yeah. So the M-43 fuel jacket finally makes its way to soldiers in Europe in 1945. No thanks to little John. What happens next? Everybody is wearing these amazing jackets and the military is cranking these things out, especially because we are on the thick of World War II and you and I both know as people of the future that there will be an atomic bomb and it will end World War II. But no one knows that the real Manhattan project is actually happening. And most people in the military did not know that. It's widely believed that this war is just going to go on for years. Yeah, like even after the theater of Europe is sort of won. Yeah. People thought we were going to invade Japan.
就像，这还要再打五年，你知道？只是给士兵装备好，去日本尽可能地占领那里。是的。是的。再说一次，这次征兵的规模是巨大的。有1200万人。这太庞大了。所以美国国内的每一家制造公司都在疯狂生产这些夹克，
Like, this was going to be like five more years, you know? Just like outfitting soldiers to go into Japan and occupy that as best they possibly could. Yeah. Yeah. Again, the scale of this draft is massive. There's like 12 million men. It's huge. And so every domestic manufacturing company in the United States is just cranking out these jackets,
为这场未来将持续下去、持续下去、持续下去、持续下去的战争储备物资。然后战争突然结束了，而且是以一种非常可怕的方式。在原子弹造成的破坏和存在主义危机的余波中，虽然在问题规模上要小得多，但仍然是一个问题，那就是美国政府拥有所有这些他们制造的衣服。是的。他们制造了太多太多的衣服。
stockpiling them for this future war that's going to go on and on and on and on and on and on and on. And then it ends really suddenly and really horrifically. And in the wake of the disdemeanor. destruction and the existential crisis created by the atomic bomb in way lesser, way lower on the, on the scale of problems, but still a problem is the fact that the United States government has all these clothes they made. Yeah. They made so, so many clothes.
就像仓库、仓库、仓库、仓库。所以他们该怎么办？他们必须摆脱它。他们必须摆脱它。他们必须尽快摆脱它。有趣的是，负责处理这些东西的人正是罗伯特·麦高恩·利特尔约翰将军，这太搞笑了。所以这就是军事剩余物资商店的由来。当然，我们以前也有军事剩余物资商店，但它们很小。它们就像小型的专业商店。我们以前从未有过这种工业规模的大规模制造，生产出数百万件这种规模的夹克。
Like warehouses and warehouses and warehouses and warehouses. And so what do they do? They got to get rid of it. They got to get rid of it. They got to get rid of it as quickly as possible. And fun fact, the person in charge of getting rid of it was none other than General Robert McGowan, Little John, which is so funny. And so this is where military surplus stores come in. And granted, we had had military surplus stores before, but they were little. They were like little specialty stores. We had never had industrial scale mass manufacturing, cranking out millions of jackets on this scale before.
对于在大萧条时期长大、没有大衣橱的一代美国人来说，这太棒了。就像军事剩余物资商店，大部分东西从来没穿过。他们会以极低的价格囤积这些东西。这就是每个人穿衣服的方式。每个人都这样穿。它甚至不被认为是一种风格。它不被认为是什么，哦，这是军事风格的东西。它只是你去买基本款的地方。
And for a generation of Americans that had grown up during the Great Depression and didn't have big closets, this was amazing. Like the military surplus store, most of the stuff had never been worn. And they would like stock these things for a song. It's just how everybody dressed. Everybody dressed this way. It wasn't even considered a style. It wasn't considered like, oh, this military style stuff. It was just like where you went to get your basics.
在沃尔玛出现之前，就有军事剩余物资商店。现在他们有了这件经过科学测试、可以在多种气候下为许多人服务的夹克，而且它真的很好。是的。现在这件曾经代表最高精致度的夹克变得人人可得，而且非常便宜。我得说，太多的男装来自这个时代，无论我们怎么说，哦，这是经典男装。这是军事剩余风格。你可以问任何品牌，即使是那些看起来只做普通基本款衣服的品牌。他们都会告诉你，它来自军队。这是蓝图。这就是20世纪经典男装风格的基石。
Before there was Walmart, there was the military surplus store. And now they have this scientifically tested jacket that can serve a lot of people in a lot of different climates, and it's actually really great. Yeah. Now it's like this jacket that was the height of sophistication is available for everyone, for really cheap. I will say, so much of menswear comes from this era, whatever we're like, oh, this is classic menswear. It's military surplus style. You can ask any brand, even ones that just seem like they make normal basic clothes. They will all tell you that it comes from the military. It's the blueprint. This is what's considered the bedrock of classic men's wear style in the 20th century.
然而，军方仍在制造衣服，并仍在科学地迭代它们。演变并没有停止。是的，因为战争在追赶他们。它们不断出现。现在是1960年代中期。越南战争正在征兵。成千上万从未上过战场的男人正在变成士兵。而这种转变的一部分仍然包括野战夹克。
And yet, the military is still making clothes and still scientifically iterating on them. The evolution doesn't stop. Yeah, because war stork them. They just keep coming. It's now the mid-1960s. The draft is in effect for the Vietnam War. Hundreds of thousands of men who have never been to war are getting turned into soldiers. And part of that transformation still includes the field jacket.
他们穿着它的新版本，升级版，叫做M65。它有一些很棒的新功能，比如卷起的兜帽，袖子上有魔术贴。但有趣的是，现在有了一条管道，军方制造的新衣服几乎立刻就会出现在剩余物资商店里。这真的很有趣。就像，我们以前从未有过这种情况，任何人都可以走进去买到士兵们实际穿的，或者看起来非常相似的东西。就像，在全国各地。
They're wearing a new version of it, the souped up version called the M65. It has some rad new features, like a rolled up hood and it's got Velcro on the sleeves. But the interesting thing is now there is this sort of pipeline where the military is, making new clothes and sort of ending up in surplus stores almost immediately. It's really interesting. Like, we'd never had this before where anyone can just kind of waltz in and buy something that is or looks pretty similarly to what soldiers are actually wearing. Like, all around the country.
这是美国时尚史上一个奇怪的时刻，也是美国军事史上一个奇怪的时刻。是的。特别有趣的是，人们有能力看起来像士兵，同时士兵们也看起来像士兵，穿着同样的衣服，完全一样的衣服，而我们对这些战争的集体感受非常复杂。非常，非常复杂。而最迷人的是，当平民和士兵开始穿得一样时，他们也有着不尽相同的观点。你知道，征兵还在继续。人们被征召到越南，但他们并不想去。
This is a weird moment in American fashion history at a weird moment in American military history. Yeah. And it is what is particularly like interesting about this moment is that people have the ability to look like soldiers at the same time that soldiers are looking like soldiers, the same clothes, exact same clothes, when our collective feeling about those wars is really complicated. Really, really complicated. And the thing that's so fascinating is as civilians and soldiers kind of start to dress alike, they have to have. they have not dissimilar opinions. You know, the draft was still going on. People were being drafted into Vietnam who didn't want to be there.
你知道，军民之间的鸿沟并不像我们今天想象的那样是一个巨大的裂缝。所以很多士兵从越南回家时仍然穿着他们的野战夹克。你开始看到他们穿着野战夹克去抗议。然后他们开始用和平标志和补丁涂改他们的夹克。这是，这是非常新的，因为再说一次，第二次世界大战后，这些只是标准夹克。
You know, like the military civilian divide is not a gaping crevasse, like we might think of it today. So a lot of soldiers return home from Vietnam still wearing their field jackets. And you start to see them wear their field jackets to protest. And then they start defacing their job. jackets with peace signs and patches. And this is, this is really new because again, after World War II, these have just been like standard jackets.
你知道，来自军事剩余物资商店的东西，就像好衣服，质量好的衣服。他们并没有在对军队发表声明。它们只是基本款。而现在，那些颠覆野战夹克的人知道他们在做什么。他们正在从军队手中夺走军事意象。他们把它变成了反战运动的象征。涂改这些东西并以这种方式在上面画画是非常冒犯的。
You know, the stuff from the military surplus stores, like good clothes, like nice quality clothes. They weren't making a statement about the military. They were just basics. And now the people who are subverting the field jacket know what they're doing. They're taking the military's imagery away from them. They turn it into a symbol of the anti-war movement. And it was so offensive to deface these things and draw on them in this way.
是的。你知道，这种采用变得如此彻底，以至于在某种程度上，看到一个人穿着军用夹克几乎就意味着是一个激进分子。你知道，它变成了一个局外人。它不是那个扣好扣子的利特尔约翰将军的士兵。是一个不同类型的角色。是的，是的，完全正确。1973年征兵结束后，
Yeah. You know, this adoption becomes like so complete that in a way, seeing a person in a military jacket indicates a radical almost. You know, it becomes like an outsider. It is not a buttoned up general little John soldier. is a different type of character. Yeah, yeah, exactly. After the draft ends in 1973,
这件夹克直接不再意味着士兵了。它意味着像年轻、不满、可能社会不稳定的年轻退伍军人。就像你在《塞尔皮科》（Serpico）和《出租车司机》（Taxi Driver）中看到的那样。它取代了牛仔布，
the jacket just straight up doesn't mean soldier anymore. It means like young, disaffected, probably socially unstable young veteran. Like you can see this in Serbico and taxi driver. Like, it replaces the denim
或者皮夹克。它成了硬汉穿的东西。它变得激进。它就像那种令人震惊的朋克东西。那么这对野战夹克意味着什么？就像所描述的那样，这是有史以来创造的最完美的军事时尚单品。而现在它与完全不同的事物联系在一起。是的。
or the leather jacket. It's like what tough guys wear. It becomes radical. It's like this shocking punk thing. And so what does this mean for the field jacket? Like this is, as described, like the most perfect military piece of fashion that's ever been created. And now it is associated with totally different things. Yeah.
我的意思是，它本质上变成了时尚，这，我的意思是，那是时尚运作的典型方式，对吧？局外人、叛逆者和朋克穿它。然后当人们开始在《塞尔皮科》和《出租车司机》中看到它时，它就开始进入主流。而且，你知道，在70年代，你真的开始，真的开始看到野战夹克的“雅皮士化”。就像，你可以看到伍迪·艾伦（Woody Allen）在《安妮·霍尔》（Annie Hall）中穿着它，当时他正等着去看电影论坛的一部独立电影。而且，达斯汀·霍夫曼（Dustin Hoffman）在《克莱默夫妇》（Kramer vs. Kramer）中饰演上西区的一位父亲，穿着它。而军队剩余物资商店意识到这现在是时尚，这件野战夹克。于是他们，
I mean, it essentially becomes fashion, which, I mean, that's the stereotypical way that fashion works, right? Like outsiders and rebels and punks wear it. And then as people start seeing it in like Serpico and taxi driver, it like starts to edge into the mainstream. And, you know, in the 70s, you really start, really start seeing like the yuppification of the field jacket. Like, you can see Woody Allen wearing it in Annie Hall as he's, like, waiting to go see an independent movie at film forum. And, like, Dustin Hoffman is a dad on the upper west side wearing it in Kramer versus Kramer. And Army surplus stores realize that this is now fashion, this field jacket. And they,
我的意思是，它本质上变成了一种时尚，我的意思是，这就是时尚运作的典型方式，对吧？就像局外人、叛逆者和朋克们会穿它。然后当人们开始在像《冲突》(Serpico) 和《出租车司机》(Taxi Driver) 这样的电影中看到它时，它就开始慢慢进入主流视野。而且，你知道，在70年代，你真的开始，真的开始看到野战夹克的中产阶级化。比如，你可以看到伍迪·艾伦在《安妮·霍尔》(Annie Hall) 中穿着它，当时他正等着去电影论坛看一部独立电影。还有，达斯汀·霍夫曼在《克莱默夫妇》(Kramer versus Kramer) 中饰演一位住在上西区的父亲，也穿着它。于是，军队剩余物资商店意识到，这件野战夹克现在成了时尚，他们，
start billing themselves as more of a fashion outpost. And the field jacket gets even further from its military origins. Surplus stores begin to cater directly to this fashion ground. They dye their field jackets, style them with belts, even draw on them. Soon the trend goes beyond the traditional surplus industry. Boutique starts popping up with a specific purpose of putting their own spin on military surplus. And one of these people is a lady named Patricia Ziegler. She was an artist in San Francisco in the 70s.
开始将自己定位为更偏向时尚前哨的品牌。野战夹克也进一步脱离了其军事起源。剩余物资商店开始直接迎合这种时尚需求。他们给野战夹克染色、搭配腰带，甚至在上面涂鸦。很快，这种趋势超越了传统的剩余物资行业。精品店如雨后春笋般涌现，专门致力于对军事剩余物资进行改造。其中一位就是名叫帕特里夏·齐格勒（Patricia Ziegler）的女士。她在70年代是旧金山的一名艺术家。
And one day, her husband came home from a reporting trip to Australia. And when he came back, he was wearing this British Burma jacket. A military surplus jacket from Australia. I noticed it right away, not because it looked military. It looked really safari rugged. It was kind of like exotic and swashbuckling looking. And she was like, maybe other people would want to buy it too. So they found a way to buy.
有一天，她丈夫从澳大利亚的采访之旅回到家。他回来时穿着这件英国缅甸夹克，一件来自澳大利亚的军事剩余夹克。我立刻注意到了它，不是因为它看起来像军装，而是因为它看起来非常有野外探险的粗犷感。它有一种异国情调和侠客风范。她当时想，也许其他人也会想买它。于是他们找到了购买渠道。
500 surplus Spanish paratrooper jackets. Okay. But, you know, they're like these weird old used jackets. They didn't really sell until Patricia started styling them a little bit. I put one on Mel with the sleeves rolled up and the collar turned up and I put on one with tight jeans and belted it. And we sold over 100. So she went home and she took two of these shirts apart and she sewed them together and she turned them into a dress. Some other ones, I took off the epaulets and made a waistband, took off the arms.
500件剩余的西班牙伞兵夹克。好吧，但你知道，它们就像那些奇怪的旧夹克。在帕特里夏开始对它们进行一点造型设计之前，它们并没有真正卖出去。我给梅尔（Mel）穿上一件，卷起袖子，立起领子，又穿上一件搭配紧身牛仔裤并系上腰带。结果我们卖出了100多件。于是她回家把其中两件衬衫拆开，缝在一起，做成了一件连衣裙。其他的，我拆掉了肩章做成腰带，去掉了袖子。
I said, doing our part for a disarmament here. And we made a skirt. And so Mel said, oh, we've got a business. I've got to find a place to open a store. So they found this tiny store that was 400 square feet. And they were like, this will be our thing. We'll take military surplus from all over the world. And we will put our own spin on it and make a fashionable, adventurous little bohemian line of clothes.
我说，我们这是在为裁军做贡献。然后我们做了一条裙子。梅尔说，哦，我们有生意可做了。我得找个地方开店。于是他们找到了这个只有400平方英尺的小店。他们想，这就是我们要做的。我们将从世界各地收集军事剩余物资，加入我们自己的创意，打造一个时尚、冒险、波西米亚风格的服装系列。
And they opened their store in 1978, and they call it Banana Republic. Isn't that crazy? That's amazing. So Banana Republic started as a sort of an international army surplus store. Yeah, basically. But early on in the 70s, Patricia realized that they were running up against a fundamental problem with their business model, which is that it was the late 70s and early 80s. and the global supply of military surplus was dwindling.
他们在1978年开了这家店，取名为香蕉共和国（Banana Republic）。这不是很疯狂吗？太神奇了。所以香蕉共和国最初是一家国际军用剩余物资商店。是的，基本上是这样。但在70年代早期，帕特里夏意识到他们的商业模式遇到了一个根本性的问题，那就是当时是70年代末和80年代初，全球的军事剩余物资供应正在减少。
And like, this is a good thing. You only get military surplus when you have a giant military and wars and huge groups of people that you have to clothe. Like, by the 80s, the United States' supply of their own military surplus was kind of dwindling. And slowly other countries were, like,
这其实是件好事。只有当你拥有庞大的军队、战争和需要穿衣的大规模人群时，才会有军事剩余物资。到了80年代，美国自己的军事剩余物资供应已经开始减少。慢慢地，其他国家也开始，
joining the fold of liberal capitalist democracies and ending their drafts. And, you know, like, this is a great problem for the world. It was very horrible for Patricia. She would be up late at night being like, I don't think we have enough clothes. Like, this stuff is getting harder to find. This is like a huge, huge problem. Yeah, especially if your business is built on international army surplus, this is a huge problem. They were like, I think we have to start making these clothes.
加入自由资本主义民主国家的行列，并结束了征兵制。你知道，这对世界来说是个大好事，但对帕特里夏来说却非常糟糕。她会彻夜难眠，心想，我觉得我们的衣服不够卖了。这些东西越来越难找了。这真是个巨大的问题。是的，特别是如果你的生意建立在国际军用剩余物资的基础上，这确实是个大问题。他们当时想，我想我们必须开始自己生产这些衣服了。
I think we have to start making them from scratch. And that was part of the reason. that they were acquired by the Gap in 1983. And that's how you start getting stores popping up all over the world, keeping the ethos of the original store, but they were mass-producing new versions of surplus, including the field jacket. Like, the Gap is making versions of field jackets with Banana Republic.
我想我们必须从零开始制作它们。这也是他们在1983年被Gap收购的部分原因。这就是为什么世界各地开始出现门店，保留了原店的精神，但他们开始大规模生产新版本的剩余物资，包括野战夹克。比如，Gap正在和香蕉共和国一起制作各种版本的野战夹克。
Yeah, yeah. So the evolution of this goes into eventually, like, you get a Banana Republic that has sort of no association with Army surplus whatsoever. You would never guess that association. So... No. Where does that leave us in terms of the field jacket? Like where would you find a field jacket today?
是的，是的。所以它的演变最终导致了现在的香蕉共和国，它与军用剩余物资几乎没有任何关联。你永远不会猜到这种联系。所以……不。那么野战夹克现在处于什么地位？你今天会在哪里找到野战夹克？
Literally everywhere. Everywhere. Everywhere. Like Prada makes a version of it. Old Navy makes a version of it. Sometimes I like to look on the street and be like how many of these are military jackets. Even if they're not dark green, it's like, oh, a four pocket jacket with some sort of cinching in the middle. It's like that's just a design of a jacket that works really, really well.
简直无处不在。到处都是。到处都是。比如普拉达（Prada）制作了它的版本。老海军（Old Navy）也制作了它的版本。有时我喜欢在街上观察，看看有多少是军用夹克。即使它们不是深绿色的，比如，一件有四个口袋、中间有收腰设计的夹克。这只是一种非常实用的夹克设计。
I was just sent a bunch of clothes from a new designer and they were like, check out our designs. And it was a field jacket. I was like, are you kidding me. They are everywhere these days. It's a classic. It's barely even associated with the military anymore. It's just a jacket.
我刚收到一位新设计师寄来的一堆衣服，他们说，看看我们的设计。结果是一件野战夹克。我说，你在开玩笑吧。它们现在随处可见。这已经成为经典。它几乎不再与军队联系在一起了。它只是一件夹克。
The field jacket started as a tool for the military to win wars. It became the symbol of a soldier. It evolved from there to something radical. And then became something stripped of meaning altogether because it's just a great-looking jacket. And the field jacket endures today, not just because of how good it looks, but how well it functions and the scientific and thoughtful way it was designed. Yeah, this, in addition to the fact that you see it everywhere and every brand makes a version of it, the fact that this was a jacket that was designed and tested in a laboratory, specifically on Chauncey, the copper dummy, this is just how clothes are made now. You know, we like can't imagine a world without this.
野战夹克最初是军队赢得战争的工具。它成为了士兵的象征。从那里演变成了一种激进的东西。然后变得完全失去了意义，因为它只是一件好看的夹克。野战夹克之所以能流传至今，不仅是因为它看起来很棒，还因为它功能强大，以及它经过科学且深思熟虑的设计。是的，除了你随处可见、每个品牌都有其版本之外，这件夹克是在实验室里专门针对铜制假人钱西（Chauncey）进行设计和测试的，这正是现在服装的制作方式。你知道，我们无法想象没有它的世界。
Outdoor brands, especially live and die by testing. So I got to visit REI. They have testing facilities for their gear that are so similar to the kinds of testing facilities that the government used. Like they have a cold room, a rain room. They even had a mannequin covered with sensors. It's like their own version of Chauncey. And so the interesting thing. thing is like beyond the practicality, this is a look. This like crunchy technical style was invented
户外品牌尤其依赖测试。所以我参观了REI。他们装备的测试设施与政府使用的测试设施非常相似。他们有冷藏室、雨室。他们甚至有一个覆盖着传感器的假人。这就像他们自己版本的钱西。所以有趣的是，除了实用性之外，这是一种风格。这种粗犷的技术风格是由
by the field jacket. This like scientifically tested looking gear. We all dress like technical soldiers now. And it's not just in the United States. We swallowed up everybody else's outdoor culture because it works and it looks cool. So in the battle between George George Dorio and General Little John. Even though General Little John was not blamed and really took no fall, he was fighting for a world that was dying. Yeah. You know, no one was going to dress in suits anymore, not soldiers, not any of us. We live in Dorio's world of scientific testing.
野战夹克发明的。这种经过科学测试的装备。我们现在都穿得像技术士兵一样。而且不仅仅是在美国。我们吸收了其他所有人的户外文化，因为它有效而且看起来很酷。所以在乔治·多里奥（George Doriot）和利特尔约翰（Little John）将军之间的较量中。尽管利特尔约翰将军没有受到指责，也没有承担任何后果，但他是在为一个正在消亡的世界而战。是的。你知道，没有人会再穿西装了，无论是士兵还是我们任何人。我们生活在多里奥的科学测试世界里。
You know, when you were first doing this or at some point in the process, when you were talking to me about the field jacket, you were like, this might be the thing that makes me the proudest to be an American. Could you expand on that? It is, it is. So I do like that this was a moment when the U.S. government took clothing really, really seriously and made really good stuff. And when our domestic manufacturing was very robust and we made these beautiful jackets that were accessible to everybody, that's point one. I really love that. And I love that they embody the democratic ideals of not looking like a European country or serving a king. it was just about individual soldier comfort.
你知道，当你刚开始做这个，或者在过程中的某个时候，当你和我谈论野战夹克时，你说，这可能是让我作为美国人最自豪的事情。你能展开说说吗？确实是这样。我确实喜欢这样一个时刻，即美国政府非常认真地对待服装，并制造了非常好的东西。当我们的国内制造业非常强大时，我们制造了这些每个人都能买得起的漂亮夹克，这是第一点。我真的很喜欢这一点。而且我喜欢它们体现了民主理想，即不看起来像欧洲国家或为国王服务。它只是关于士兵个人的舒适度。
But I also love what it gave to America. I mean, people went to military surplus stores, and they bought these jackets, and they bought, you know, tents and backpacks and other things, and they went hiking. You know, this is before outdoor stores were prominent. You know, it helped expand our relationship with the outdoors. Like, it was mitigated through these clothes
但我同样喜欢它给美国带来的东西。我的意思是，人们去军事剩余物资商店，买了这些夹克，买了帐篷、背包和其他东西，然后去徒步旅行。你知道，这在户外商店普及之前。你知道，它帮助扩展了我们与户外的关系。它通过这些衣服得到了缓解，
that were suddenly available to everybody. And I love that moment in the 1970s, And I think about it a lot now, that the people who are rebelling against the war, you know, the jacket was a very strong anti-war statement, but it wasn't anti-soldier. You know, they were sort of all wearing it together. Yeah, yeah. Speaking out against the actions of the government, but not of their fellow citizens. It's truly a jacket for the people. And then, of course, it's a great design.
这些衣服突然间每个人都能买到了。我喜欢70年代的那个时刻，我现在经常想到它，那些反抗战争的人，你知道，这件夹克是一个非常强烈的反战声明，但它并不反士兵。你知道，他们都在一起穿着它。是的，是的。反对政府的行为，而不是反对他们的同胞。这确实是一件属于人民的夹克。当然，它也是一个伟大的设计。
So I just think this is the best thing since sliced bread. This is, like, the most amazing. invention and the fact that it's so incredible and we don't even notice it as you know it's like that's a sign of great design it is i had never thought about it before well this has been a really fun tour through the field jacket thank you so much avery truffman i really appreciate it thanks roman the story of the field jacket comes from avery's fantastic show articles of interest she devoted the entire sixth season to gear and the field jacket is just one part of it the whole thing is amazing check it out at articles of interest dot ceo special thanks to
所以我认为这是自切片面包以来最好的发明。这是最令人惊叹的发明，而且它如此不可思议，我们甚至没有注意到它，你知道，这是伟大设计的标志。确实是。我以前从未想过这一点。好吧，这是一次关于野战夹克的非常有趣的旅程。非常感谢你，艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffman），我非常感激。谢谢你，罗曼（Roman）。野战夹克的故事来自艾弗里的精彩节目《感兴趣的物品》（Articles of Interest）。她将整个第六季都献给了装备，而野战夹克只是其中的一部分。整个节目都很棒。请在 articles of interest dot ceo 查看。特别感谢
to costume historian Charles McFarland for his research on the topic. A history of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. This episode was produced by Isabel Angel. Our series producers are Priscilla Al-A. B. Brenna Dahldorf and Ellie Lightfoot. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Mixing by Iver Manly.
服装历史学家查尔斯·麦克法兰（Charles McFarland）对该主题的研究。《美国历史与100件物品》是99% Invisible和BBC Studios的联合制作。由我，罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）主持和策划。本集由伊莎贝尔·安吉尔（Isabel Angel）制作。我们的系列制作人是普里西拉·阿尔-A. B.（Priscilla Al-A. B.）、布伦娜·达尔多夫（Brenna Dahldorf）和艾莉·莱特福特（Ellie Lightfoot）。我们的助理制作人是艾萨克·费舍尔（Isaac Fisher）。本系列由安妮·布朗（Annie Brown）和考特尼·哈雷尔（Courtney Harrell）编辑。混音由艾弗·曼利（Iver Manly）完成。
Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. From BBC Studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright. Artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Serious XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful, Uptown. Oakland, California.
事实核查由艾米·布拉肯（Amy Bracken）完成。我们的主题曲由Swan Real创作。来自99% Invisible，我们的执行制片人是凯西·2（Kathy 2）。来自BBC Studios，我们的执行制片人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作协调员是珊·帕莱（Shan Palais），制作经理是梅布尔·芬尼根·赖特（Mabel Finnegan Wright）。艺术设计由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）完成。99% Invisible是Serious XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区。
And BBC Studios is headquartered in beautiful, White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 Objects at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
BBC Studios总部位于美丽的伦敦西部白城。如果您想联系我们或有物品供我们考虑，请发送电子邮件至 100 Objects at 99PI.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。